-I love having
you here on the show.
You look gorgeous, by the way,
as always.
-Are you feeling sticky?
I'm covered in lube.
I'm sorry if I touched you.
[ Laughter ]
It's latex.
I'm not always covered in lube.
-Yeah.
-Very occasionally.
-That makes two of us.
-Once in a while.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so happy you're here,
you know.
Let's talk -- I don't know
if you can talk about this.
But backstage
I was saying hi to you
and I saw your phone screensaver
is a picture of Brian Cox.
-Yes, it is.
-Yeah. That's interesting.
-Yeah, I love that man.
-Did you love "Succession"?
-I do love "Succession,"
but I love that --
I did a movie
with him a couple of years ago,
and he's sort of vaguely
been in my life
since I was a child anyway,
because he was like best friends
with my godfather.
-I love him.
-Yeah, I love him so much.
And he's got this strange
kind of testicular pull that
when I'm in a low moment,
he feels a call
in a fatherly way
and calls me up
and pulls me out of trouble.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-I just went
on a roller coaster right there.
[ Laughter ]
-It sounded a bit funny.
No, that came out wrong.
But I had a bit of a rush
getting here.
-Yeah, no problem.
-I was in a testicularly frame
of mind.
Sorry, everyone.
But no, he's lovely,
and he just --
I find it very comforting
every 30 seconds
when my phone relaxes.
And there he is.
-What movies did you
do with him?
Do I know it?
-Well, I did a really bad movie
with him when I was about 19,
and everyone in it
was brilliant.
It was Christian Bale
and Helen Mirren
and all these incredible people.
And the movie was awful.
And it was a sort
of retelling of "Hamlet,"
but it was dreadful.
And so Brian was my dad in that.
But I think he was quite cross
about he could tell the movie
was going to be terrible,
so he was not as approachable.
So he was, yes,
because he was a bit grumpy
because all the sets
were wobbling
and he kept falling off
his horse and things like that.
[ Laughter ]
And I was still
at university anyway,
so I was just like, "I'm here."
And then this time
I just played his daughter
in a movie
called "Prisoner's Daughter,"
and I am the prisoner's daughter
and he's the prisoner.
-Wow. So, yeah.
So you bonded well.
Shout-out to Brian.
He's a good guy. We love him.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I learned this about you.
You obviously spent
a lot of time now in America.
-Yes.
-And I was surprised last time
we talked that you've never had
American cereals.
-Well, because I didn't smoke
any weed.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you don't have
to do that to have it.
-It is the law.
-No, no, no.
But I thought maybe
it could be fun tonight
to have you try
some American cereals.
-Are you trying to kill me?
They're all funny colors.
-No, these are all natural.
These are all-natural colors.
-This is a breakfast item?
This is for children?
-Yes.
-You're trying to kill --
What is this?
-That is Lucky Charms.
-Has it got
Flintstones vitamins in it?
-No, they're marshmallows.
-That's the hardest
marshmallow I've...
[ Laughter ]
That's no marshmallow.
-Would you try some?
-Sure.
-Should I put a little...
I have a little milk here
for you.
Alright.
-That's Lucky Charm, is it?
-That's Lucky Charm, yeah.
Yes, you can try that.
There's spoons for you there.
-Not to be gross,
but do I have to swallow?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-You don't. I have a bucket
here, in case you -- Yeah.
-Just special occasions.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No. Smile. Chew.
It's really good.
-Ugh! It's like thick
all over your teeth.
It's already swallowed.
It swallowed itself.
[ Laughter ]
How did that happen?
-It just disintegrated?
-It just went away.
-It went away.
That's Lucky Charms.
Alright, now try -- I think --
-I'm going to be running around
the parking lot
at high speed after this.
-Here we go.
This is Froot Loops.
-Okay.
This you give to babies.
I've seen babies
with handfuls of these.
Or is that something else?
-I think that's Cheerios.
-That's not the same thing?
-No.
-They look the same.
-No, they would love these.
But I think -- I want
to see your reaction
because I think
you're going to love these.
-Mm.
-No.
-Again. Okay. And it is gone.
[ Laughter ]
-But did you get a different
flavor than that
or it tastes the same?
-That was a lot.
That felt like it maybe
had some form of grain in it.
But I feel like it's for people
who have no teeth.
This is for gummy -- This is --
-Yeah, they're pretty hard.
I mean, you got to
really chew on those.
But did it taste
like fruit to you?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
It's not supposed
to taste like fruit.
-Yes.
-No.
That's better than that, though.
That's the devil's crumble.
[ Laughter ]
-The devil's crumble.
-I should've used my napkin.
-That's a good name for it.
Yeah. No.
Oh, yeah, of course. Alright.
This one, this is called --
This is called Cap'n Crunch.
Cap'n.
-Cap'n.
-So it's a pirate cereal.
It's for pirates.
-Yes.
-No, the pirates for that one.
-No, that's a leprechaun.
-Of course it is.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a leprechaun.
That is a cartoon toucan.
-Okay. You're not well. I love
you all, but you're not well.
[ Laughter ]
-What's in this?
This is small --
-I can't explain it to you.
-Okay.
It's just an experience.
-Yeah, it's an experience,
Cap'n Crunch.
It's crunchy.
So you have to chew this one.
-I hope so.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, I'm chewing it.
-Yeah, It's crunchy.
-It's still in.
It's still there.
-Still there.
-That I could mess with.
-Yes. Really?
-Yeah.
-Cap'n Crunch?
-Yeah. That one's okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you want to try
one last one?
-That looks like it's going
to give me
immediate bowel movement.
What is that?
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's not.
None of these are that healthy.
I got to be honest.
But this one, I feel like --
-That looks like fiber.
-Do you like cinnamon?
-Not hugely,
but I'll give it a go.
-Alright. This is
Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
-This is another crunch. So are
they cousins related somehow?
-Oh, because
they're named Crunch?
I never put the 2 and 2
together, to be honest.
They could be related.
Yeah.
Cinnamon Toast Crunch
and Cap'n Crunch.
Maybe this is like
a lieutenant or something.
Or someone less than captain.
If you like cinnamon, though,
you have to like --
It's pretty good.
-I'm going to get IBS from this.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no, no, no, no.
-Absolutely not.
Give it back.
No, absolutely. I'm so sorry.
-That's like
a Christmas decoration.
That is horrible.
Oh, no, I'm definitely --
-That is out. Alright.
Wow! That gets spit out.
Alright, The winner
is Cap'n Crunch right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow! I love you.
Thank you for playing along
with us. You're always so fun.
I can take your napkin.
-This was okay.
I was genuine. Not even lying.
I didn't mind it.
-I love that you did this.
Thank you very much.
-I'm sad I didn't like the one
with the leprechaun,
since that's technically
nearer where I'm from.
-Yeah, you're always down
for doing something fun,
and I appreciate that.
You know what I like about,
by the way, this movie?
I like seeing you in a comedy.
-Oh, me too. I know.
-Because I know you're dramatic.
You're a great actor,
but you're very funny
if you get --
if you know you.
I mean,
if you follow your accounts,
your Instagram account
is so fun.
-Oh, thank you very much.
Yeah, it was really nice.
And, like,
Charlie Day is so funny.
And my daughter says, you know,
"Before I'm your daughter,
I am a Charlie Day fan,"
which kind of sucks.
-Wow. Wow.
-She just loves him.
-But the cast is all-star cast.
Charlie Day, Jason Sudeikis.
-All the great Jasons.
Any Jason.
-Jason Bateman.
Anyone named Jason
is allowed in this movie.
-All the really cool Jasons.
-Yeah, the best
Jasons are in this movie.
But you also have
John Malkovich.
You have Ken Jeong,
You have Adrien Brody.
-Edie Falco.
-Edie Falco. Adrien Brody,
by the way, very funny in this.
-Super funny.
And again, I was -- and also,
just take a moment.
We have Ray Liotta who passed.
And I'm so sad because
I'd known him a long time.
I love him.
And he's brilliant in this.
-Yeah.
-But yes, Adrien doesn't
come off like he's going to be
a barrel of laughs either.
He's like me, but he is.
He's hilarious.
-Hilarious.
-And how was Charlie Day?
Because he directed it
as well, right?
-He directed, yeah.
So he was very busy running
about on his little legs.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, he was great.
He doesn't speak in the movie.
So the movie is basically
Ken Jeong
is a very down-on-his-luck
publicist
who wants to kind of
break into Hollywood.
And there's a tricky,
difficult actor
who won't come out
of his trailer.
And they managed to find
someone who's kind of mute
and not really quite right
in a mental asylum
who looks just like this actor.
So they sort of throw him
into the movie
pretending that
he's this movie star,
and he never really
gets to say anything.
It's because everyone else
is talking so much.
So he doesn't speak
at all in the movie.
So it's his kind of
Chaplin thing.
Don't be put off by that
because it is really funny.
And I'm his kind of horrific
movie star costar
who then immediately wants
to marry him and adopt children.
-It's funny. It's fantastic.
-As we all do.
-Very clever.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kate Beckinsale
and Charlie Day
in "Fool's Paradise."
Take a look at this.
-He's about to leave
his wife, right?
And I can't have him smiling.
Laddy, laddy.
No, no, no smiling.
-The script says
look sorrowful, so...
-Just do nothing!
-It doesn't say do nothing.
It actually says look sorrowful
if you have the sides.
-Elaine.
-I'm just gonna...
-Bill, is it my clothes,
my hair?
Is it the fact
that we's cousins?
-He's blinking now.
Look. Look at her.
Look -- Look -- Look at her.
Her! Yeah.
Look at the pretty dirty lady.
Yes!
-Have it your way, Billy.
I hate your guts anyway.
[ Audience groans ]
-Now she's doing it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kate Beckinsale.
"Fool's Paradise" is in theaters
May 12th.
More "Tonight Show" after the
break. Stick around, everybody.